I want you to remember I said see this
stuff here this stuff I'm about to rub
off
remember I said like these particular
numbers they take some fancy calculus
differentiation integration blah blah to
actually prove that those numbers of the
right moment okay well I want to come
back to calculus we haven't spent much
time we can't calculus in the context of
these things I've got a function it's a
polynomial when I see functions and
polynomials in calculus the easiest
thing I can do with this thing is um
differentiated right how can
differentiate differentiating super easy
with polynomials so if that's F of
capital X what's F - capital just - just
think about it think about it write it
with me right with me let's actually not
skip any simplify steps is pretty simple
right f dash of capital X oh I should we
should say by the way where X is equal
to capital X is equal to hmm oh you know
what actually all this should be feared
sorry but that's okay it's just a label
don't worry about - let's differentiate
shall we um first term there's an R at
the Front's just the concepts I'm just
gonna pull it out first term what is
this guys this is this is what the term
is one so different yet to become zero
this is just X so when I differentiate
it it becomes one I differentiate this
guy you get 2x on 2 factorial 2 X on 2
factorial is 2x on 2 which is X right
ah sorry yet bloggers what this one you
differentiate this guy you get 3x
squared so you expect but it's on three
factorial so that's three x squared on
three factorial which is on two
factorial
isn't it do you need me to differentiate
the next one for you isn't the next one
execute now hold on a second hold on a
second I recognize this
I recognize this that's exactly what it
is I recognize this guy this is f of
capital X isn't it now a wonder wonder
what kind of function there is that is
its own derivative you differentiate it
you get well that that means this must
be has to be e to the X there's no other
function that does that it's the only
function in all your years of schooling
that when you differentiate it it gives
you back itself do you see what I did
you see what I do let me just make sure
because this is that right there at the
end we went from this actually we
reference we went from this to be
truthful right where for this
now I'm sorry I read this drawback on is
to let me rewrite all these are theatres
yeah but I don't want to confuse it with
this X so just imagine these are all
theatres is that okay so in fact I
really want this to say I feed on okay
so just just be play imagination with a
okay so I start from this I use just
wide angle triangles to get to this then
I do some we are fancy stuff to get to
this and then I just played a little bit
so there's a series there but I just
said let's just differentiate for thank
you because like good differ kidding and
then this guy came up
but capital X is my field right and what
this function is is just a single
complex number to Z so therefore this
whole thing is actually e ^ there's also
an R there because remember that
factored out remember that so this guy
here just like every other one that
we've encountered as a name
we met the rectangular form we met the
polar form under originally this is
called the exponential form
now what this means is I can write any
complex number like that just like I can
write 1.75 as one in three quarters or
seven quarters or 175 percent I believe
it or not that was all leading up I can
finally tell you this thing it gets
better
come back to um I have to redraw it cuz
I've to leave mine but if you go back to
your diagram where you drew this guy
over here right and you said he was our
outside all of this do you remember that
okay see you've drawn them have a
wonderful thing about this now that I
notice is it R and theta they're just
numbers numbers the IP right R is the
radius of this circle right the radius
of this circle and theta is this angle
here measured from the positive real
axis this is this is real okay not X
this is imagined
okay now can beginning on July 18 on
this I like
so the particular numbers that I'm
interested in our radius of one and this
angle by the way has a special name it
comes like something called an argument
an argument of PI radians okay now just
look for a second just tell me which is
roughly what what number of radians to
keep down a bit like PI on one looks
like pi/3 to me ish okay fine three
minute plan 2 is here yeah / - 9 Aires
where's PI pi PI comes back all the way
over here right pi radians would be here
right and this circle has a radius of
one tonight define it to be 1 this is
the unit circle so this number of a hit
is point is negative 1 right so if I
were to write this over here of radius
of 1 e to the power of I the theta that
I chose that's apparently equal to this
number that's where I am
that's the complex number where I am
that's the position named 1 all I need
to do is really get a tiny tiny bit and
this is the most beautiful identity in
all of mathematics and because of who I
am I happen to think that means it's one
of the most beautiful objects in
existence just contemplate this for a
moment okay this is it this is called
Euler's identity no surprise where those
are pretty the virginias okay
just have a look there are there are
five numbers there are five numbers in
this line okay can you see them they are
all special let me start from the back
inside I know you're like what is that
okay zero is what we call the additive
identity it's what you add and nothing
changes you're still identical right and
also it means that what you got over
here it perfectly balances for the
extension two students think about like
MIT forces zero right it's like force
force force equals zero means you know
inertia right
zero is the first number one this is
where everything started
right this is counter we call it the
multiplicative identity because you
multiply one and the number doesn't
change then you have a look at this guy
this is the number of circles pi is the
number of circles what's he doing in
here
well as about a surprising anything else
it's in here with the square root of
negative one it's great negative one and
where do we meet this remember when we
met me yeah it's that it's the number of
growth right I introduced a tegu through
this remember it was early last year I
said if you've got compound interests
all right and you compound more and more
frequently which means you add smaller
and smaller amounts of interest if you
do that you get to eat in fact that's
that's what this is that's what the
limit is so you put together the number
of exponential growth the square root of
negative one which you can't measure but
it's there you can do bats with it the
number of circles and that perfectly
balances out with one that's the most
beautiful identity every mathematician
agrees beats equals mc-squared
for energy anyway this is the real age
right it beats Maxwell's equations for
the electromagnetic spectrum etc it
beats everything this has every single
superstar athletics
so what we've done right what that sort
of gets at is that when you think in
terms of imaginary numbers you no longer
think about just growing and shrinking
on this scale you're thinking about
going around a circle remember I said oh
what picture should we head by it's kind
of like a propeller right and so that's
what takes you around to maybe when it
rotates okay I kind of like to think of
it like a mathematical TARDIS it's kind
of bigger on the inside you sort of look
at it and you're like well that's very
unassuming you know so few characters
and yet there's a world what do you do
with the middle this on I'll tell you
you couldn't have um you couldn't have
given me a better lead into my
conclusion which is when you say Oh what
what can you do with this right well
lots of mathematicians have thought
about this and as they stand these are
the kinds of things they say it's
absolutely paradoxical we don't know
what it is or what it means but it's
true it is unavoidably true or if you
want to get a little more poetic
like a [ __ ] sorry sonic right or a
painting that's why I said the Mona Lisa
okay you've got all of these numbers
that are fundamental to the fabric of
reality and they are all connected in
this mysterious way